PlayStation VR launches on October 13th
and it will include a free demo disc
with eight games I'm Tony and this is
your virtual GameSpot news update the
first demo is driveclub
VR featuring a new point of view for the
racing game
second is PlayStation VR worlds the demo
will feature ocean descent one of five
virtual reality experiences from the
full game
third is rigs mechanized combat league
and arena combat game with fighting
mechs fourth is the puzzle stacker
tumbler VR and fifth is the Cobra tank
game battlezone space shooter Eve
Valkyrie is demo number six and airborne
adventure game wayward sky is number
seven finally you'll get a demo for head
master the pseudo soccer game with a
twist please note that these have been
confirmed for the European demo disc and
the US lineup may differ police-station
VR requires a ps4 and PlayStation camera
to operate but you can get the headset
by itself for four hundred bucks you can
also get a bundle that includes the
headset to move controllers a
PlayStation camera and PlayStation VR
worlds for five hundred there are plenty
of games on their way to the headset and
you can be sure we'll be talking about
them at GameSpot for all the biggest VR
news you're already in the right place
Oh